[موسيقى]
عندما تكون ثريًا بما يكفي لامتلاك
أي شيء لا تريده فقط شراء ما
يمتلكه شخص آخر بالفعل مثل
بنتلي الذي يصنع بالفعل بعض
السيارات باهظة الثمن ، قرر أن ينتقل
بالحصرية إلى مستوى آخر
فقط سيكون لدى عشرات الأشخاص واحد من
هذه  السيارات التي
صُنعت من أجلهم ، هذه هي بنتلي باكالار ،
إنها كبيرة باهظة الثمن وغير
عملية إلى حد
ما ، لقد حاولنا صنع
سيارة مصقولة بالفعل بشكل فعال للغاية
في أي وقت من الأوقات كان لدينا خطة
لجعل سيارة فائقة الأداء
مثل  مثل
السيارة الحصرية للغاية التي لا يزال بإمكانك استخدامها
كمنتج يومي ، نعم بخلاف أنها
لا تحتوي على سقف ، لا يوجد
سقف ل bakalar ولكن هذا جيد مع العملاء ،
يقول بنتلي إنهم وافقوا جميعًا على
قمرة القيادة المفتوحة بأسلوب speedster
آه
أنا  يعني أنها بنتلي 12 أسطوانة ،
فلماذا لا يوجد سقف
بدون سقف تمكنا من الجمع بين
الداخل والخارج عندما لا
يكون لديك سقف ، يمكنك جعل
تدفق المقصورة يتجه إلى محيط
الخارج
وهكذا وهذا  هذه  تدور السيارة كثيرًا
حول التصميم ولغة التصميم
وأردنا إنشاء شيء من
الجمال الاستثنائي ،
وبالتالي
ستبدأ أسعار هذه البكالوريا المصممة خصيصًا من حوالي 2
مليون
ولكن بالطبع قد تكلف الكثير
اعتمادًا على الخيارات التي يريدها كل عميل
لإضافة ذلك ،
ستكون كل سيارة عميل مختلفة تمامًا ،
فجميعها مرقطة الآن وكل سيارة
لها شخصيتها المطلقة ،
لذا فمن غير المحتمل إلى حد كبير ، ولكن إذا
تصادف اثنان من البكالوريا بنتلي يقفان
بجوار بعضهما البعض ،
فلن يشعر أحد بالارتباك مثل
ندفة ثلجية بقيمة 2 مليون دولار لكل واحدة
ستكون فريدة من نوعها